I'm Brandon this is Michelle
who just got engaged and we're gonna be
getting married in July this year when I
think about the holidays just think
about family and hanging out with
friends lots of hugs and stories and
just sharing meals Michelle and I are
having a holiday dinner party with
friends and we can't wait to see what
Sam and Brenda prepare for us I'm Sam
Mason I'm the chef/owner of Oddfellows
ice cream in Brooklyn New York the food
that I'm inspired by for the holidays is
my favorite food to cook being able to
work with someone like Brenda and to see
someone else's outlook I think it's
gonna be very exciting
I'm Brenda Terry I'm the beverage
manager for the Tampa Yacht & Country
Club for me the holiday season is really
about putting things on hold and kind of
seen where you are I'm really looking
forward to have the opportunity to work
with Sam to see what I can bring to the
table until we can kind of marry those
two creative elements
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my visual my mind's eye if you will saw
this as a full table spread kind of a
kind of a feast I think it's very
holiday s right you know you take
something in then you pass racks I take
some you take something so just to kind
of touch on in a little more details to
the aperitif cocktail
you can't think holiday without thinking
bubbles so it's champagne and then of
course sapphire East and I wanted it to
feel like a Christmas cocktail that
you've never had before but also
familiar at the same time one of the
dishes is the sweet potato mousseline
with burnt marshmallows it's essentially
it shows some sweet potatoes a little
bit of a vanilla it eats on the sweeter
side because it is covered in burnt
marshmallows so touch on the entree
cocktail is gonna start with Bombay
Sapphire and add a little of Sirocco
white port Sheen r70 has that kind of
weird turn of events with the artichoke
and all the bitter components and a
little bit of herbal nuts and then
Benedictine house-made cranberry cider
syrup some dashes of Angostura bitters a
little bit of citric acid solution and
we're gonna finish with allspice
tincture and then of course the garnish
is gonna be pickled cranberries with
fresh thyme that's gonna be wrapped
around a skewer and kind of remind you
of those Christmas trees to make a real
pretty just to make it pretty I should
move some allspice from that cocktail
over to the ham it's gonna be glazed in
maple cinnamon and whiskey I guess in
the seer I could throw a bunch of
allspice in there because it just gets
pretty much washed for the two hours
it's in the oven
once you cut into it the key is to have
enough glaze to where a slice actually
carries the flavor of the outside
character so it gets to be a little
intense on the outside but you don't eat
that by itself you
with the entire slicing means so I love
when when you can pair cocktails and
food together in a really nice way it's
it's fun with this event we're really
looking forward to just having a really
nice meal with some friends and just
really looking forward to seeing what
kind of food comes out from Sam and of
course the drinks from Brenda as well
Michelle and I want to thank everybody
for coming in today and starting off
this holiday season so this punch is
actually it's a Sapphire gin touch it
should feel warm and cozy hopefully and
it makes you want to go to like a little
fireplace so we're gonna start you guys
what it's some ham on your plate which
has been cooked with a whiskey cinnamon
a lot of clothes lot of allspice I think
this dinner for me really helped me kind
of like get in that beautiful mood of
getting back and being really grateful
for I am and just seeing people smile
and be really you know receptive to what
you're offering I think it was a
beautiful way to kick off what the
holiday season is all about this video
is exciting for me because I love the
holidays and to see you know that the
place that I put together tonight
you know enjoyed by a group of great
people like this that was exciting for
me it was it was it was a very sincere
evening it felt like a great way to
start off the holiday season with my
friends and just just kind of sitting
around the table and Joey
company Cheers
hey guys thanks for watching we had a
beautiful holiday party and if you
enjoyed that you should subscribe to the
GQ channel